miles de trabajadores públicos y
jubilados marcharon en el corazón de
Caracas exigiendo mejores salarios y
pensiones que actualmente apenas
equivalen a 7 dólares mensuales
una cifra insuficiente para costear las
necesidades diarias tengo dos años que
no como apoyo y tres que no como Carne
no como Carne no tengo zapatos no puedo
poner ni un par de zapatos nuevos porque
eso no me alcanza
uso una medicina porque estoy enferma
pero bronquios y la medicina vale 140
dólares yo no lo puedo comprar porque yo
no cobro esto trabajadores de sectores
esenciales como la salud y la educación
también marcharon exigiendo aumentos en
los salarios Aunque aclararon que no
piensan realizar una huelga
estamos hoy aquí en esta concentración
todos los sectores de Salud Educación
los jubilados y pensionados exigiéndole
al gobierno salario dignos tenemos unos
salarios miserables los maestros estamos
ganando ni siquiera para vivir
dignamente
es el tercer día consecutivo protestas
del sector público en Caracas en 2023
junto a los jubilados continúan
reclamando por la homologación del
salario y las pensiones a la canasta
básica además de seguridad social